Manuel Jiménez es productor Bananero
desde hace 25 años
es uno de los 2000 productores que
debieron cambiarse de rubro o cerrar su
negocio de un total de 8.500 tras el
inicio de la guerra en Ucrania el cierre
de su finca fue inminente y ahora está
vendiendo sus tierras
están con una producción casi muy baja
al 30 40 por ciento otra del 50 por
ciento entonces la producción está
demasiado baja se volvió Incontenible se
busca alternativas de vender tratar de
diversificar los cultivos Es realmente
fue una catástrofe como que un misil
cayó acá en Ecuador la quiebra de
productores se incrementó debido al
aumento de un 100% del precio de
fertilizantes narcisa galófagos sostiene
que sin poder pagar los altos precios es
difícil mantenerse a flote la excusa es
de lo que el gas de estrógenos que no
pueden elaborarlo
entonces aún así llega caro Entonces
como yo siempre digo pues si yo compro
para vender Entonces si a mí me lo
venden caro yo también lo tengo que
venderlo pues no Franklin Torres es otro
productor que permanece en el mercado
dejó de exportar 2000 contenedores de
banano a consecuencia de la guerra
significan 60 millones de cajas que se
perdieron desde el año 2022 hasta la
fecha hoy en el país tenemos cerca de
dos millones menos de cajas por semana
lo cual realmente perjudica a todos
perjudica a los productores
perjudica al país porque hay menos
ingresos también perjudica a los
trabajadores
pérdidas que afectan directamente a
Islas Cervantes cocinera en una finca
bananera teme perder su empleo porque
cada día cocina para menos empleados
poco pensativa porque Imagínese yo con
ese trabajo mantengo a mis hijas porque
yo para mis hijas soy padre y madre y
eso yo o sea yo pienso si
me falta este trabajo cómo hago mientras
la guerra en Ucrania continúe la pérdida
de cosecha se mantendrá sin mejoras para
los agricultores en el año 2023